[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de mode d'emploi avec un focus
sur le retour des métiers industriels
un volet consacré à la formation sans
oublier notre rubrique sur les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
qui recrutent
voici le sommaire le secteur industriel
offre un très large panorama de lutte
et une filière dynamique sur notre
territoire filière est en constante
évolution avec l'arrivée des nouvelles
technologies
nous irons notamment à poigne air dans
une entreprise propose des services
domotiques et des métiers industriels du
futur auquel on peut se former au sefi
l'école connecté au futur de l'industrie
à montigny le bretonneux propose
notamment de formation en gros potiron
domotique
enfin si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi ne manquez pas notre rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises qui recrutent
avec le pôle emploi de plaisir et la
gendarmerie nationale à saint quentin en
yvelines
on compte environ 21 mille emplois dans
le secteur automobile
dix sept mille emplois dans
l'aéronautique des métiers industriels
manuel est quelque peu délaissé mais qui
connaissent un regain d'intérêt ces
dernières années avec notamment
l'arrivée des nouvelles technologies
tout de suite on fait le point lorsque
l'on pense aux métiers liés à
l'industrie on a bien souvent ces images
qui nous viennent à l'esprit des métiers
manuels qui sont nombreux sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
en raison de la présence de grands
groupes
ils sont représentés dans l'automobile
ou encore l'aéronautique
mais depuis quelques années avec
l'arrivée du numérique l'industrie s'est
renouvelée par exemple chez airbus
defence and space à elancourt la réalité
augmentée a fait évoluer ses métiers on
travaille sur des outils internes qui
vont pouvoir nous aider à produire des
avions plus rapidement
avec meilleure qualité mais aussi après
on peut développer des produits pour des
clients notamment dans le domaine de la
défense pour pour l'armée où pour la
sécurité civile ou même pour airbus
commercial autres branches à s'être
développées ces dernières années la
domotique à coignières la société
protect 2000 emploie une vingtaine de
salariés spécialisée dans la fermeture
et la sécurité des bâtiments et propose
également des solutions pour améliorer
le confort des habitats quand on fait de
l'automatisme à un moment donné on a des
clients qui nous demandent bon ben voila
moi
je veux pouvoir piloter un porte de
garage je veux pouvoir piloter mon
portail mes volets roulants et je veux
pas avoir 40 télécommande donc la
domotique à viendra en fin de compte que
ce soit des systèmes de
vidéosurveillance ou encore des systèmes
anti intrusion la domotique demande de
nombreuses compétences l'automatisme et
la connaissance de tout ce qui est donc
l'électronique l'électromécanique c'est
une compétence et un savoir-faire qu'un
technicien de aux abois il un deuxième
aux priorités qui doit connaître c'est
que je vais le simplifier en disant que
ça doit être un geek pour quoi un geek
c'est parce qu'il doit connaître à tous
les opérateurs tous les systèmes
d'interconnexion les box et savoir avec
son smartphone comment tout cela est
articulé des technologies qui ont poussé
les métiers industriels classiques à se
renouveler à évoluer et ainsi être plus
attractif des métiers industriels qui
offre de nombreux débouchés mais pour
lesquels vous l'avez vu eh bien il est
nécessaire d'avoir une formation
adéquate
je vous propose justement de voir toutes
les formations proposées au sefi de
montigny le bretonneux
[Musique]
les cff et où l'école connecté au futur
de l'industrie propose une offre de
formation dans plusieurs pôles de
compétences ici à montigny le bretonneux
4 kilomètres carrés sont consacrés à
l'apprentissage de la robotique de
l'énergie ou encore de la domotique
elle margotton bonjour bonjour vous êtes
responsable du pôle de formation sur le
site de montigny
alors ici peut être formé à combien le
métier alors au niveau du cfi sur le
site de montigny on peut nous on
fonctionne plutôt en filière c'est à
dire conforme aux métiers dans trois
filières l'électrotechnique la domotique
qui fait une filière ensuite nous avons
l'électronique robotique et les réseaux
et génie informatique
alors quel type de formation vous
proposer alors nous nous faut nous
formons du bac à bac + 5
c'est à dire que un jeune qui rentrent
par exemple avec un bac que ce soit un
bac général un bac technologique ou un
bac professionnel peut se faire un
parcours de formation en ciblant déjà au
demeurant un peu sont une compétence clé
quand même soit sur l'électronique soit
effectivement sur l'électro technique
soit sur l'informatique et ensuite peut
se faire un parcours pour aller jusqu'à
bac +5 en passant par le cap du bts de
la licence professionnelle jusqu'à un
titre de niveau 1 donc de niveau bac +5
ingénieur et ce sont des formations
exclusivement en alternance et ce sont
des formations exclusivement en
alternance nous ne formons que des
apprentis
[Musique]
une centrale intrusion avec des
détecteurs donc des détecteurs de
mouvement alors l'on se trouve devant
une platine de travail pour un système
intrusion alors ça sert à quoi
on apprend alors à câbler donc avec tout
ce qui est derrière tous les câbles donc
nous quand on arrive en 1ère année de
bts ont câble c'est cette patine on a
fait fonctionner on fait des mesures et
donc on apprend aussi tout ce qui est
énorme réglementation avec ses platines
vous vous êtes étudiant en licence
coordinateur de projet immo ticket
objets connectés
pourquoi vous avez choisi cette
formation alors j'ai choisi cette
formation car représente pas mal de
choses parce que je voulais faire après
mon bts
donc c'est à dire tout ce qui est
management coordination de projets
[Musique]
je suis un robot humanoïde nous sommes
dans la phase de cours dédiés à la
formation chef de projet informatique et
robotique avec nous florent montanier
bonjourbonjour également peppers que
vous venez chez florence quoi nous
présenter tes peurs donc pepper est un
robot de chez softbank robotics on vient
juste de l'acquérir dans notre formation
et on est impatient de pouvoir
programmer sur ce robot dans le cadre de
notre formation en master manager
robotique et informatique dans qu'est ce
qui vous plaît dans cette formation
concrètement alors il ya beaucoup de
alors je suis pas trop j'aime pas trop
la théorie en général dans les cours
pour vous dire j'étais pas super forts
en maths ou et donc du coup la robotique
ce que j'adore c'est que
vous programmez quelque chose finalement
et que vous obtenez un résultat est que
vous voyez développe enfin vous voyez
votre développement réel est ce que ça a
donné le fait fi de montigny accueille
chaque année 400 jeunes en alternance
plus de 80 % d'entre eux trouvent un
emploi immédiatement après la fin de
leur formation des métiers industriels
qui nécessite des connaissances pointues
voici donc ce qu'il faut retenir tout
d'abord nous allons voir le métier de
dôme au titien ou d'homo titienne pour
cela il faut obtenir un diplôme en
domotique en deux ou cinq ans après le
bac
le salaire est compris entre 1300 et
2200 euros nets possibilités d'évolution
ingénieurs domo titien en plus des
qualités techniques il est bon d'avoir
des aptitudes commerciales
deuxième métier techniciens ou
technicienne de maintenance que ce soit
dans l'industrie automobile ou
l'industrie aéronautique
il faut un bac pro ou un bts maintenance
des systèmes pour la rémunération
compter environ 1500 euros nets en début
de carrière possibilités d'évolution
responsable de maintenance
le petit plus dans ce métier savoir
s'adapter aux nouvelles technologies
alors maintenant si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un emploi et bien un petit
conseil prenez de quoi noter voici deux
offres proposées par l' agence pôle
emploi de plaisir ainsi qu'une offre de
recrutement de la gendarmerie nationale
bonjour je suis guéri drief un chargé de
relations entreprises au pôle emploi de
plaisir et je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui deux opportunités d'emploi
donc la première opportunité concerne le
restaurant le taux mises en demeures aux
clayes-sous-bois l'établissement propose
des postes de serveurs un poste de
responsable de
salle et un poste de cuisinier alors
pour les postes de serveurs vous
disposez d'une aisance relationnelle
vous êtes polyvalent et accepter les
contraintes horaires liées au secteur de
la restauration pour le poste de
responsable de salle et le poste de
cuisinier
vous justifiez ou d'une première
expérience significative dans les
métiers ou d'une formation initiale et
savez faire preuve de rigueur et
d'organisation dans votre travail
la seconde opportunité d'emploi
concernent le foyer de résidence camille
claudel à villepreux
l'établissement propose un postes
d'aides-soignants et un poste d' aide
médico psychologique
vous êtes impérativement diplômés dans
ces métiers à savoir
vous êtes titulaire d'un diplôme d'état
d'aide-soignant ou d'un diplôme d'état
d'aidé médico psychologique pour le
poste des deux médico psychologique
vous devez également être titulaire du
permis b les débutants sont également
acceptés pour ces postes
bonjour je suis là chaque céline je suis
sous-officier aux recruteurs au centre
d'information et de recrutement de la
gendarmerie de paris
actuellement nous offrons plus de 7000
postes de gendarmes adjoints volontaires
que ce soit dans le domaine opérationnel
technique ou administratif
nous recherchons des personnes motivées
mobile géographiquement ayant le goût
pour l'action
vous pouvez nous retrouver sur le site
internet www.lalsace.fr ou bien venir
nous rencontrer directement au centre
d'information et de recrutement de la
gendarmerie de paris au 12 place de la
république
situé dans le 10e arrondissement de
paris et si vous êtes une entreprise
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer vos offres
de recrutement en vidéo à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran emploi @
sky point fr c'est bientôt la fin de ce
mode d'emploi mais avant de se quitter
bien voyons ensemble les rendez vous qui
vous attendent
mardi 28 novembre l'association créée
active association qui rassemble 130
femmes chefs d'entreprise à saint
quentin en yvelines organise des
rencontres sur le thème entrepreneurs
osons parler d'argent c'est demi
10 à 20 heures au ch'ti cuba guyancourt
inscriptions sur le site
www.crackstv.com org
enfin si vous voulez en savoir plus sur
les métiers de l'ingénierie
rendez vous le mardi 5 décembre à la
cité des métiers de trappes entre 14h et
16h plus d'informations sur le site
www.citechaillot.fr c'est la fin de ce
numéro merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi 5 décembre pour un
nouveau mode d'emploi consacré cette
fois ci aux métiers du btp à très
bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]